[Música]
si os digo que Rusia está tirando la
casa por la ventana para financiar la
gran Ucrania seguro segurísimo que a
ninguno de vosotros os va a sorprender
es más todos Ya sabéis que en septiembre
de 2022 Rusia comenzó a movilizar a
300.000 personas para la guerra pero es
muy posible que no sepáis nada de esto
Rusia empleará el tamaño de sus fuerzas
armadas a 1,5 millones de soldados según
el ministro de defensa y kremelin
consideraba anteriormente que el tamaño
de las fuerzas armadas rusas era
suficiente Pero eso cambió tras
experimentar una resistencia inesperada
y reveses en Ucrania el ministro de
defensa ruso sergeygu ha anunciado esta
ampliación pase lo que pase en Ucrania y
ojo porque esto tiene implicaciones
enormes hablamos de un esfuerzo mucho
mayor de lo que puede parecer a simple
vista pensadlo bien desde que comenzó la
Guerra de Ucrania la de 2022 más de
700.000 personas la mayoría de ellos
jóvenes han abandonado el país Por qué
pues para evitar ser llamados a filas y
terminar metidos en una trinchera o bajo
tierra en donbas Pues bien untado ahora
esta fuga de cerebros con Las bajas
sufridas en la guerra y el grave
problema demográfico que llevaba
acarreando Rusia durante décadas
básicamente están perdiendo población Y
entonces Os daréis cuenta del gigantesco
reto que supone destinar otras 500.000
personas más a las fuerzas armadas
hablamos de medio millón de jóvenes que
no estarán disponibles para estudiar O
para trabajar y a los que además habrá
que equipar mantener y pagar un salario
entre unas cosas y otras hablamos de que
el mercado de trabajo ruso puede perder
más de 1,3 millones de jóvenes en un
país que ya de por sí tenía bastantes
pocos jóvenes pensad que hablamos de una
sociedad donde solo el 10% de la
población tiene entre 19 y 29 años según
los pronósticos que hicimos antes de la
pandemia para el año 2030 el número de
trabajadores con entre 20 y 40 años se
reducirá aproximadamente una cuarta
parte respecto al año 2020 esto en sí
mismo supondrá un cambio tectónico y
tendrá un gran impacto para la economía
a esto Ahora se suman las pérdidas que
estamos presenciando la fuga de
profesionales y los jóvenes movilizados
para la guerra doctor Vladimir Jim
person director del centro de estudios
del mercado laboral de la escuela
superior de economía de Moscú Pero eso
no es todo fijaos en este gráfico
como podéis ver en pantalla Rusia ya ha
empezado a invertir fuertemente en
defensa Es lógico porque está en una
guerra pero si os fijáis entre 2021 y
2022 su gasto militar se incrementó en
un 50 por ciento y ojo porque no es que
vinieran de gastar poco en defensa si el
compromiso de la otan es del 2% del pib
destinado a gasto militar Y hasta ahora
pocos países lo cumplían Rusia casi
nunca ha bajado del 3% y ojo porque en
Ucrania Rusia ya ha perdido muchísimo
equipamiento militar hablamos de más de
2.300 tanques miles de vehículos
blindados cientos de sistemas de
artillería 12 buques de guerra casi 140
aviones y helicópteros de combate Y por
supuesto miles y miles de toneladas de
misiles y munición de todo tipo y Qué
significa todo esto Pues que si quieren
reponer todo ese Arsenal van a tener que
gastar muchísimos rublos Durante los
próximos años y Eso sin contar el
esfuerzo de una guerra que continúa y
claro esto ya de por sí sería un enorme
reto en cualquier circunstancia con una
economía que no crece o crece muy poco y
que además está siendo castigada por
unas sanciones internacionales
hasta ahora la economía rusa más o menos
ha resistido a las sanciones pero las
cosas a futuro sobre todo en el largo
plazo se ven Mucho menos a la huella de
eso ya hemos hablado recientemente aquí
en visualpolitik y no digamos ya si
finalmente se aprueban las temidas
sanciones secundarias es decir un tipo
de sanción que no castiga Rusia sino a
los países y las empresas que convergen
con Rusia esto podría ponerlo muchísimo
más difícil a Rusia para puntear esas
sanciones ahora bien os habéis dado
cuenta de una cosa hablamos de mucho más
gasto militar y al mismo tiempo menos
trabajadores y menos dinero los que
tengáis el Colmillo un poco retorcido
quizás estéis pensando que Rusia podría
terminar convirtiéndose en una especie
de Corea del Norte gigante es decir una
economía de guerra un país donde la
mayor parte de los recursos se destinan
a las fuerzas armadas y también por
supuesto al bolsillo de Kim Jong en este
caso al bolsillo de Vladimir Putin Claro
está en Corea del Norte todo
absolutamente todo gira en torno al
ejército y la defensa nacional en
cualquier caso Rusia está muy lejos de
ese escenario Pero de dónde va a sacar
todo el dinero que necesita para
mantener todo este esfuerzo bélico que
puede suponer todo esto para la economía
rusa y para el día a día de los rusos
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
cuestión de prioridades
[Música]
la pregunta que todos os habéis hecho
alguna vez es cómo es posible que un
país como Rusia que tiene un pibe
similar al de Italia Canadá o Brasil sea
considerada como todo una potencia
militar O al menos lo Era recordáis
haber visto algún vídeo hablando sobre
el ejército brasileño o el ejército
canadiense en plan Vamos a comernos el
mundo seguro que no pero claro en Rusia
el peso de las fuerzas armadas es
gigantesco de hecho la mayor prioridad
de Putin a lo largo de los más de 20
años que ha estado en el poder ha sido
precisamente esa renovar y fortalecer
las fuerzas armadas dejando de lado
muchas otras cosas por ejemplo el 20% de
los rusos ni siquiera tienen algo
corriente en casa esto se da sobre todo
en las regiones más frías y más pobres
Por qué Pues porque apenas hay
infraestructura por ejemplo una cosa
sorprendente de Rusia es que apenas
tienen puentes mientras en Estados
Unidos hay alrededor de 600.000 puentes
Rusia que es 1,7 más grande en
territorio solo tiene entre 40.000 y
70.000 puentes vamos que Rusia siempre
ha gastado mucho en defensa porque no
gastaba en otras partes esto también
ocurría en la época soviética o los años
de yelseng Y por supuesto con Putin en
el kremlin el gasto militar Es
simplemente Intocable atentos
como podéis ver a partir del año 2012
Vladimir Putin comenzó a incrementar el
esfuerzo militar de Rusia y lo hará aún
más Durante los próximos años cuando
seguramente el gasto militar termina
situándose muy por encima del 5% del pib
Y no sólo eso además de gastar mucho más
en el ejército el gobierno de Putin
también sacó adelante su famoso plan
fortaleza Rusia una estrategia que
buscaba prepararse para la guerra y
sobre todo para llegado al caso poder
soportar las sanciones internacionales
por ejemplo redujeron la deuda externa
aumentaron las reservas de Divisas y
trataron de reforzar sus lazos con Asia
y Oriente medio lo que se llamaba el
pivot hacia el este lo cual hablaremos
más largo y tendido en otros vídeos
digamos que durante años el objetivo
primordial no fue hacer crecer la
economía sino sobre todo preparar al
país para una eventual Guerra y esto en
cierto modo es lo que les ha permitido
aguantar también el castigo de occidente
durante el último año Claro que la
pregunta que podemos hacernos ahora es
todo esto está muy bien pero toda esta
previsión será suficiente para mantener
el esfuerzo de guerra en los próximos
años es decir que está haciendo Rusia
para evitar una crisis económica fuerte
y seguir financiando la guerra Pues
básicamente está haciendo tres cosas
para eludir las sanciones
internacionales
primero está tratando de incrementar
todo lo que puede sus ventas de petróleo
y gas a países como China o la India
para intentar compensar la pérdida de
sus clientes en Europa 2022 las cosas le
fueron relativamente bien gracias a que
los precios del gas y del petróleo se
pusieron por las nubes Rusia consiguió
ingresar casi un 20% más que en años
anteriores pero en el año 2023 y los
próximos años pueden ser muy diferentes
sobre todo si no consigue vender mucho
pero muchísimo más en Asia este sería su
primer gran objetivo Claro que no
resulta Tan sencillo entre otras cosas
porque los chinos A diferencia de los
alemanes y casi todos los demás países
europeos sí se toman en serio la
seguridad energética es decir que no
quieren depender demasiado de un gran
proveedor por eso lo segundo que está
haciendo Rusia o mejor dicho el kremlin
es colocar en estos mercados a
intermediarios con fuerzas conexiones
con el gobierno ruso que compran el
petróleo de este país con descuento y
luego lo revenden en el mercado a otros
países a precios de Mercado dicho de
otra forma que occidente pone un tope al
precio del barril de 60 dólares no hay
problema pongo una empresa rusa en la
India por ejemplo que compra el barril a
los 60 dólares y luego lo vende al
distribuidor Indio Por el precio de
Mercado que tiene el barril de petróleo
en ese momento y la diferencia se la
queda Rusia de esta forma podemos
saltarnos todo lo que queramos el tope
al precio del gas
y finalmente la tercera estrategia
importar de terceros países que no puedo
comprar tecnología occidental no hay
problema países como kazajistán o
kirguistán que no están sancionados
importarán lo que haga falta y luego se
lo revenderán a Rusia eso explica que de
repente las importaciones en Armenia por
ejemplo se hayan disparado en 2022 por
supuesto el proceso es más caro las
cantidades son limitadas y lo que se
consigue pues por lo general no es la
última tecnología Pero al menos sirve
para cubrir agujeros por ejemplo para
seguir fabricando armas
ahora bien esta estrategia podría
haberse truncada si finalmente se
imponen las sanciones secundarias aunque
esto es tema para otro vídeo ahora bien
todo esto Explica cómo Rusia puede
sobrevivir a las sanciones pero el
kremlin necesita mucho más es decir que
no basta con aguantar El golpe sino que
también tienen que rearmar a su ejército
y ampliarlo y la primera pregunta es es
esto suficiente para lograr la victoria
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la sombra rusas
todos lo sabemos incluso Quienes no
quieren reconocerlo la guerra en Ucrania
le está yendo francamente mal muy mal al
ejército ruso sin ir más lejos aquí en
visualpolitik ya os hemos contado Cuáles
son las principales razones por las
cuales está fracasando el ejército Ruso
y desde luego noticias como esta nos
deja muy claro cómo están realmente las
cosas el ejército no tiene nada los
nuevos reclutas rusos lamentan la falta
de suministros los familiares compran
equipos y ropa para los soldados en
primera línea debido a los robos la
corrupción y la mala logística y esperar
porque aún hay más los nuevos soldados y
reclutas no solo carecen de que el
equipamiento suficiente sino que tampoco
han recibido prácticamente entrenamiento
y cuando entran en el frente es habitual
que muchas veces la comida se retrase o
incluso llegue caducada o que por
ejemplo no existan planes sobre donde
refugiarse y ni siquiera se trata solo
de que estos soldados apenas reciban
equipos entrenamiento y suministros
muchas veces también sufren malos tratos
sí en este canal ya os hemos hablado por
ejemplo de la famosa the door china es
decir las crueles novatadas a las que se
someten a los nuevos soldados que en
muchos casos llevan mental y físico pero
es que además hay más Los Altos rangos
militares también se niegan a informar a
las familias de los soldados sobre su
situación y esto Aunque parezca mentiras
bastante habitual en el ejército ruso ya
pasan Afganistán y volvió a pasar entre
chania donde Por cierto llegó a ver
casos de madres que fueron a buscar a
sus hijos a las zonas de combate es
decir que es bastante habitual que las
estructuras militares en Rusia tratan a
soldados básicamente como Carne de cañón
el resultado Pues que como ya hemos
visto la moral está por los suelos
falta de equipos falta de preparación
falta de suministros problemas con la
cadena de Mando es la receta perfecta
para el fracaso que es exactamente lo
que explica lo ocurrido la pregunta
ahora es y qué pueden hacer en qué están
pensando exactamente en Moscú Pues
básicamente en tirar de talonario ya
hemos visto como han disparado su gasto
militar
ahora lo que Putin le ha pedido a su
gobierno Es que alimenten la industria
militar con nuevos contratos y más
pedidos el problema El problema es que
la corrupción el desfase tecnológico Las
sanciones y la baja productividad hacen
que esto sea una misión particularmente
difícil incluso Aunque puedan comprar
ciertos suministros en países como
Armenia para colmo el gobierno ruso
redujo en 2020 sus pedidos militares lo
que ha hecho que muchas líneas de
producción estén hoy cerradas por
ejemplo mientras que entre 2011 y 2020
el país estuvo produciendo entre 8 y 12
bombarderos su-34 anualmente el contrato
de 2021 a 2024 prevé la fabricación de
tan solo 5 al año
lo mismo pasa con algunos misiles
guiados como los de la clase tornado en
este caso tenemos datos de los modelos
9m-544 y 9m 549 hablamos de misiles
guiados con un Rango de unos 150 km Pues
bien en 2017 se produjeron entre 220 y
230 unidades un año después en 2018 la
producción bajó a unos 150 y en
principio no hay evidencias de que la
fábrica que fabrica estos misiles pueda
aumentar la producción Por qué pues
principalmente por falta de mano de obra
veréis se estima que la industria de
Rusia necesitaría unos 400.000 nuevos
trabajadores simplemente para seguir
trabajando como hasta ahora y como os
podéis imaginar entre los rusos que han
abandonado el país y los que se van a la
guerra la mano de obra escasea pensad
que para fabricar armas modernas se
necesitan profesionales cualificados
Rusia No solo está perdiendo a sus
mejores profesionales Es que además
tiene problemas para atraer a
trabajadores cualificados del extranjero
conclusión este gasto militar irá
principalmente a fabricar armas menos
avanzadas artillería tanques de
herencias soviética etc Así que la
pregunta es qué está pasando ahora en el
resto de la economía rusa Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
Big Mac madding Rusia
por si algunos lo estaba preguntando no
Rusia no está entrando en una economía
de guerra Quedaría muy bien un titular
clickbait comparando a Rusia con Corea
del Norte pero es que las magnitudes no
son comparables por ejemplo según las
estimaciones de Estados Unidos en el año
2021 Corea del Norte llegó a destinar un
26% de su pib en defensa en el caso de
Rusia en el peor de los casos podríamos
hablar de un 6% pensad que Rusia tiene
una economía muchísimo más avanzada y
diversificada
además el mejor argumento de Putin es
que las sanciones internacionales están
afectando poco a los rusos pero claro si
de repente decretara una economía de
guerra y obligará a muchas empresas a
trabajar exclusivamente para el ejército
ese panorama podría cambiar por completo
los mercados empezarían a quedarse
desabastecidos la inflación Seguramente
se iría por las nubes y si la guerra no
terminará pronto las consecuencias
podrían ser catastróficas este es uno de
los grandes problemas que tiene el
ejército ruso necesita equipos mano de
obra y todo tipo de suministros pero al
mismo tiempo el kremlin necesita tener
apaciguados a los rusos
y diréis que ha pasado entonces con
todas las empresas occidentales que se
han ido del país pues cosas como esta
los restaurantes McDonald's de Rusia
reabren bajo una nueva marca con el
nombre de kusnan tosca sabroso y ya está
la cadena de comida rápida parece una
copia del original estadounidense Exacto
mis queridos amigos de visualpolitik
Rusia ha vuelto a ofrecer comida rápida
a sus ciudadanos aunque esta vez del big
Mac no está en el menú
básicamente un oligarca Ruso Alexander
gobor ha comprado todos los restaurantes
de McDonald's en Rusia este hombre tenía
ya la franquicia de McDonald's en varias
regiones sobre todo en la zona de
Siberia Pues bien Ahora se ha quedado
con el negocio de toda Rusia y hasta ha
prometido que abrirá nuevos restaurantes
por ahora ha mantenido toda la plantilla
de más de 60.000 trabajadores y diréis
vale en principio las hamburguesas de
McDonald's son perfectamente
sustituibles pero qué pasa con los
sectores más tecnológicos pues por
ejemplo vamos a ver los automóviles tras
marcharse los grandes fabricantes como
Renault ha llegado el momento de oro
para las marcas locales atentos a esta
noticia El fabricante ruso de coches de
la era soviética regresará Rusia con la
ayuda de China según un informe Dos de
cada después de su quiebra la empresa
automovilística de la era soviética
moscreach plantea un Renacimiento en
Rusia al parecer asociándose con El
fabricante chino JC para producir
vehículos en medio del Éxodo de las
principales marcas por su parte lada va
a volver a producir su mítico Grand the
Classic del 2011 Eso sí con tecnología
de los años 90 y sin airbags ABS ni
cinturones de seguridad dicho de
hablamos de productos de peor calidad
pero hechos en Rusia
El caso es que casos como el de lava o
la nueva cadena de hamburguesas rusas
son el claro ejemplo de cómo Rusia está
reconvirtiendo toda su economía por
supuesto estas empresas serán mucho
menos productivas fabricarán cosas
obsoletas y difícilmente serán
alternativa pero esta estrategia de
nacionalizar la economía con empresas
rusas puede ayudar a evitar el desastre
a corto plazo incluso Este cambio y el
mayor gasto militar del gobierno pueden
hacer que el pib se mantenga Eso es en
buena medida lo que explica Por qué
algunas organizaciones como el fmi
apuntan a que la economía rusa puede
incluso crecer un 0,3% en 2023 sin
embargo esto tiene trampa producir
misiles por ejemplo puede contribuir a
mejorar la cifras de un año pero una vez
que se utilizan se pierden y lo que
queda es la enorme factura que ha tenido
que pagar el gobierno y algo muy
parecido ocurre con la producción de
heladas de mucha peor calidad
y por otro lado tenemos un problema de
escasez de mano de obra y aquí es donde
está el gran problema de Rusia en estos
momentos y no creáis que es un problema
pequeño porque sin talento es imposible
levantar una economía en otras palabras
que ahora mismo Putin está pidiendo
demasiado a su tejido productivo pero
llega desde este punto turno para
vosotros conseguirá Putin desconectar la
economía rusa de occidente y volver a
crecer y hasta qué punto logrará
sostener el esfuerzo de guerra logrará
solventar los problemas del ejército o
terminará decretando una economía de
guerra podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios y como siempre no
olvidéis Que aquí en visualpolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos Todas las semanas
así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]